they come from a world of Photoshop and
airbrushing so it's no wonder
supermodels always look perfect but are
they still showstoppers when they bare
it all for makeup free photos if you are
first-time viewer click the red
subscribe button and enjoy today we are
discussing ten shocking photos of
supermodels without makeup Gigi Hadid
she is one of the biggest supermodels
right now and for good reason
Gigi Hadid is simply stunning known for
her beautiful eyes in tone bod she has
graced the pages of Sports Illustrated
Swimsuit Edition and is considered a top
model but if you strip away all her
makeup is she still a stunner of course
she is
Gigi proves that she can be just as
beautiful with makeup as she is without
Selita Ebanks it's hard to believe that
top model Selita Ebanks is well into her
30s considering she's up against
teenagers and girls in their 20s Ebanks
is still being booked all over the world
what is even more impressive are her
shocking photos without any makeup
the supermodel looks exactly the same we
aren't even sure why she would need
makeup as she has no flaws to cover and
his stunning own natural cara delevingne
cara delevingne is the modeling
industry's it girl right now she's even
been able to have a pretty successful
acting career which proves she isn't
going anywhere the model actress is
known for her unruly thick eyebrows and
natural good looks so it's no wonder
when she bares a fresh face for
Instagram she still looks amazing the
girl can even pose with a frog and no
makeup and still pull it off Joan Smalls
Joan Smalls is one of the highest-paid
models in the world and looking at her
there was no surprise why'd the
beautiful Puerto Rican model has been at
the top of the modeling game for over
seven years and as a staple on the
Victoria's Secret runway she is known
for her amazing bone structure and
symmetric features then when you take a
look at her without makeup it's not hard
to see why she earns millions as a
supermodel
the woman is flawless kendall jenner
she's grown up in front of the camera
and has been able to use her family
success to launch a modeling career
kendall Jenner is now one of the most
sought out supermodels and has been
appearing on runways all over the world
she's never been one to shy away from
taking photos without makeup and it's
easy to see why she has amazing skin and
striking features and we can't help but
to fall in love with her freckles
Jenner's yet another example of natural
beauty in the modeling industry Jazmin -
when it comes to spotting beautiful
women Victoria's Secret has a great eye
just look at Victoria's Secret alumni
Jasmine - so well-known lingerie brand
was so impressed with coops that she was
the lucky model who wore the iconic
Fantasy Bra during the 2016 Victoria's
Secret runway show but how does she look
without all the amazing lighting and
makeup exactly the same that's how her
skin is flawless and she has a megawatt
smile what is not to love Bella Hadid
after seeing a success of older sister
Gigi it was only natural for Bella Hadid
to launch a modeling career of her own
she has graced the Victoria's Secret
runway along with her sister and was
even named gqueues 2016 model of the
year she is known for her mysterious
gaze and fully pouty lip even when the
young model takes off her makeup she is
still a beauty she is known to rock her
natural face on Instagram where she
posts bare face selfies for her fans
slice ribeiro considering life Ribeiro
started her modeling career as just a
teen she has come a long way she was
even a mother of a one-year-old before
she began to model she's been able to
not let anything hold her back she's
built an impressive modeling resume
she's been a vs angel since 2010 and his
work for Tom Ford and Ralph Lauren it's
easy to see that Ribeiro is a natural
beauty and it's confirmed when we see
photos of her without makeup
she's almost exactly the same and she
definitely doesn't look like the mother
of an almost 10 year old Lily
Eldridge Sports Illustrated swimsuit
model Lily Aldridge has been modeling
for half her life model scouts could see
at a young age that algid was stunning
not much has changed since the girl is
still gorgeous and on runways everywhere
but what do we see when the supermodel
trades in her glam look for something
more natural we see her amazing uncon
toward cheekbones and perfect eyebrows
that's what the girl doesn't seem to age
and she's so beautiful as ever even
without makeup Kate Upton Kate Upton has
Peru
the power of the internet over someone's
life she was basically discovered by a
video of her dancing that went viral
since then the glamorous Upton has been
able to launch an incredible modeling
and acting career
she's even the cover model of 2017
Sports Illustrated swimsuit edition
not only does she have the career that
many models only dream about but she may
also look even better without makeup her
amazing natural features don't need any
masking which is probably the reason she
is a world-famous model in the first
place what do you think about these
shocking photos react in the comments
section below and don't forget to like
this video and subscribe to the things
you